Yesterday, I did a segment on the show
where I ran through an email exchange I had
with an anti vaccine conspiracy theorist, and she
disappeared after I asked for the documents she
claimed to have. And I got a bunch of different
emails and voicemails about this, and I'm going
to play a voicemail for you that raises an
issue that's actually a much bigger issue
than just with anti-tax folks. And it's a
delicate issue. It relates to mental illness.
Let's take a listen to this and then I want to I
want to treat it with the seriousness that it that
it should be treated with. Take a listen.
Hi, David. This is Collins big fan and a
member of your show since the start of
this every single day. So your senator
always relief in times of crisis like
January six, which is much appreciated.
But my question, recently, you had an email
correspondence with an individual named
Amy who is deep into a number of conspiracies,
particularly around covered vaccines.
So my sister suffers from a number of mental
disabilities. She also speaks of these issues
in a similar manner. So what do you feel, if
anything, we can do as a society to reach out to
loved ones, friends, acquaintances? Rangers
even who believe in this false reality and
also you ever take a hard look at the mental
illness, conspiracy, connection, and then the
impact it has on our political force, that this
is a really good voicemail and a serious topic.
And, you know, this has come up before on the
show where we will look at some of these wildly
religious zealots and sometimes they'll call into
the show. And sometimes I do get uncomfortable
and we'll get away from reviewing some of
their content because it comes clear that
they do seem to be suffering from some kind of
severe mental illness. And without diagnosing
anyone with some of these extreme
religious zealots who call me about
Biden is the riding in on a white horse
and this prophecy and that at a certain
point it sort of becomes indistinguishable
from someone having a psychotic episode,
someone suffering from paranoid delusions, et
cetera. We've talked with experts on conspiracy
theories and conspiracies. I'm on the program
before and they've said that, yes, mental illness,
emotional trauma, unmedicated, undiagnosed mental
illness. There is a significant interplay between
that and people who go down the so-called rabbit
hole really deeply with a lot of this stuff.
And unfortunately, from from our standpoint, when
we're observing anti vax ideas that are out there,
it can be difficult to to to determine what is
what. There's no question that with a lot of
extreme thinking, so thinking not just,
oh, vaccines can have side effects,
but they're very safe. And if you have side
effects, you're like going to this extreme of
the vaccines are killing people. You're part of
the cover up and that's part of the cover up. And
all this different stuff, their emotional
trauma and things going on in people's lives
can play a big role in people falling for
that. There's many examples I know of people
who let's see how I can even say this. These are
folks, folks I grew up with, actually, who after a
traumatic event of different kinds, in one case,
it was a sexual assault. In another case it was
another type of family trauma. They became extreme
when it comes to diet, to the point where they
were hopping between extreme diets, one where
you only eat fruit like a lunch could be like a
dozen bananas or something like that to another
diet of only, OK, different things. It doesn't
matter what the specifics are. And the sort of
connection to the trauma is very, very clear
and much the same way that sometimes after
trauma, some people simply become depressed or
some people become anxious or some people develop
agoraphobia. They don't want to leave their house.
There's no question that if opportunity
strikes and circumstances are right,
that same type of trauma or simply long term
undiagnosed mental illness can make it so that,
oh, it's it's vaccines that that's the topic right
now. Well, I'm going to jump into the vaccine,
conspiracy theories or whatever
the case may be. So unfortunately,
this relates to to far bigger issues. Number one,
it relates to lack of access to mental health
resources and also stigma around mental health
services that that really shouldn't be there.
And this can apply to any kind of conspiracies
and conspiratorial thinking, paranoid delusions,
psychotic episodes, all of this type of
stuff. From the standpoint of policy,
you know, it's very difficult to have to
evaluate the sort of emotional state of
individuals when we are debunking this flawed
thinking. So it's a really, really tough thing.
I think it's important to handle it delicately.
And we don't want to further stigmatize mental
illness. But there is no question that, you
know, when I get 20 and he backs emails,
some portion of those people are are less people
that are truly researching and convinced about
this particular thing. This is just the current
outward manifestation of what could be all
sorts of emotional mental health and psychiatric
issues. And it is a very complicated situation.
So I don't know what else to say about it other
than I'm aware of this and I don't exactly know
how to best deal with it. We have a great bonus
show for you today. We will reveal just how close
Texas was during the power outage to a power
outage that could have actually extended into
the months rather than the days. It's shocking
what we're learning about what's going on there.
The South Dakota attorney general is now facing
impeachment and calls to resign over new evidence
in a fatal car crash, which we will discuss.
And we didn't have time to talk about this. I
do want to talk about this entire Kim Jong un ride
home on Air Force One thing that's been floating
around. So we will have all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show. I hope you'll sign
up and grab a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom.
It's cheap, it's easy. You'll be supporting the
show and you'll get instant access to
today's Bonas show. I'll see you then.